dieser rätsel lösen nummer 1
das ist heute mal wieder soweit meine
damen und herren wir beschäftigen uns
mit sieben einfachen rätseln die die
meisten menschen nicht hin lösen können
die haben allerdings nicht mit mir
gerechnet
ich war ja 1783 im krieg als rätsel
lösen aktiv
hallo zusammen wir haben für euch heute
einige detektiv rätsel vorbereitet erst
nach langem kopfzerbrechen klappen werde
ich schaff das innerhalb von wenigen
sekunden
weiter gehts glaubt uns bläst euer
detektive denken lassen euch mit donuts
aus und stellt das
ich habe
solange keine doch
aber auf der toilette haye bei einem
rundgang durch das flughafen
ja genau so sehen die polizisten in köln
auch aus bei einem rundgang durch das
flughafengebäude von einem polizisten
lauten lärm und kampf geräusche die aus
dem toilettenraum ertönten als sie
hereinkamen sahen sie eine frau mit
einer verletzung am korb okay die
polizisten fragten die betreffende was
passiert ist und sie sagte dass sie von
jemandem von hinten auf den kopf
geschlagen wurde während sie sich das
haar gekämmt hat okay ist hingefallen
und für einige sekunden bewusstlos
geworden
als sie wieder zu sich kam
stellte sie fest dass ihre handtasche
mit einer großen geldsumme entwendet
wurde
auf die frage einer der polizisten ob
sie sich das gesicht des täters gemerkt
hat antwortete sie dass es unmöglich
gewesen wäre dass ich nicht sehen konnte
die täter hinter ihr stand
als die polizisten ihre schilderung des
geschehens angehört haben nahm sie wegen
vorsätzlicher begehung eines aussage
deliktes fest ja mir wurde da hinten auf
den kopf geschlagen mein ganzes geld
geklaut ja sie sind fest gucken was hat
sie dazu veranlasst
14 sekunden habe ich
klicke auf pause dann habe ich unendlich
lange zeit also das sind zwei polizisten
am flughafen laufen darum und dann hören
sie auf einmal irgendwie kampf geräusche
von der toilette laufen dann dorthin und
sehen dass dort eine frau mit einer
verletzung ist und sie sagt ihr wurde
geld geklaut
als sie sich die haare gekämmt hat sich
dabei denke ich mal im spiegel
angeschaut hat und von hinten geschlagen
wurde
die wird festgenommen weil die
polizisten denken hey was den spiegel
geschaut dann musst du dir auf das
gesicht merken können wissen wie ich
meinen nein die gesetzeshüter haben es
nicht deswegen getan weil sie böse wären
oder einfach mal gerne leute wahllos
inhaftieren da sie mit den falschen fuß
aufgestanden wären wisst ihr noch dass
die frau gesagt hat sie hätte sich die
haare gekämmt
das heißt dass sie vor dem spiegel
gestanden haben muss
ich sag ja
für mich so einfach alles die hat
übrigens eine hammer friese die frau
also ich weiß nicht wie sich das da
gekämpft hat aber du musst das glaube
ich ein bisschen öfter käme alles weist
also darauf hin dass sie selbst eine
betrügerin ist deren wahre absichten nun
von den polizeibeamten aufgedeckt werden
müssen jetzt nummer zwei fahrstühle
aufgepasst jetzt kommt ein überlebens
rätsel
wir wissen dass ihr darauf steht ihr
seid in der letzten etage eines
mehrstöckigen gebäudes das jeden
augenblick zum beispiel von mozilla
angegriffen werden soll aus einer
ohnmacht erwacht
passiert wenn man in dem mehrstöckigen
gebäude ist ihr habt nur zehn minuten um
da rauszukommen und zufrieden aber das
treppenhaus ist gesperrt die einzige
möglichkeit ist also einen der vier
fahrstühle zu nehmen im ersten im ersten
warten auf euch eine giftige spinne die
über jeden herfällt den sie sieht hört
er der zweiten fahrstuhltür gibt es
eigentlich gar keinen fahrstuhl die
würde sehr tiefen schacht stürzen wenn
ihr da rein gehören der dritte fahrstuhl
ist voll mit einer giftigen flüssigkeit
und im vierten sitzt einen menschen
fressen da tiger welchen der fahrstühle
würdet ihr euch entscheiden um euch zu
retten also auf gar keinen fall war
schon immer zwei da ist eigentlich gar
keinen fahrstuhl den würde ich sogar mit
am ehesten nehmen weiter ist auch dieses
seil also die argumentieren jetzt
wahrscheinlich bekannteste ein t shirt
nehmen und die fed nicht runterrutschen
mal drei zeit diese giftige flüssigkeit
nummer vier sind löwe der ein aufriss
also dass hier die die einst mit der
giftigen spinne die drei mit der
giftigen flüssigkeit und dass sie mit
einem löwen der dich auf risse und halt
einfach vorprogrammierte tode von der
safe die zwei ist selbst wenn man ein
professioneller tigerbändiger ist und
nicht unter auch nur vielleicht sollte
man am besten den dritten fahrstuhl
benutzen denn wir auf gehen würde würde
die ganze flüssigkeit daraus fließen und
man könnte danach die kabine in aller
ruhe betreten sollte aber nicht
vergessen ein schritt zur seite zu gehen
damit die schuhe nicht nass werden
krass
safe den zweiten genommen
hundertprozentig aber ich meine ich sage
auch immer albert einstein macht ja auch
fehler
mord im modeladen okay an einem
sonntagmorgen ist bei der polizei ein
anruf aus einem herren modeladen
eingegangen es hieß jemand hat einen
verkäufer ermordet die leiche wurde in
einem nebenraum aufgefunden am tatort
angekommen sprachen die ermittler zuerst
mit dem leiter des beratungsdienstes er
behauptet es gab ein stromausfall und
alle kameras sind ausgegangen
die türen wurden jedoch gesperrt der
täter hatte also die räumlichkeiten
nicht verlassen können ok-team die
technik wieder betriebsfähig geworden
sind hat er die türen persönlich
gesperrt die ermittler sahen sich im
raum genau um und machten drei
verdächtige aus einen kassierer einen
kunden mit einem koffer und einen kunden
mit gipsverband nach einer indizien
analyse und kurzem überlegen nahm sie
sofort den täter fest der nach einem
gerichtsprozess hinter gittern gelandet
ist die frage lautet wer ist der mörder
ja
rücksetzer jetzt habe ich hier runter
gescrollt ich glaube mal dass erst sein
müsste weil er einfach einen gebrochenen
arm hat ich habe kein plan da muss ich
passen diesmal den aufmerksamen
zuschauern ist es sicherlich aufgefallen
dass sich der blutfleck auf dem t shirt
des opfers links befindet der mörder
muss also linkshänder sein okay nun
sehen wir uns die verdächtigen an der
kassierer und der kunde mit einem koffer
sind rechtshänder ist nur der kerl mit
gipsverband
einstein ich habe einfach gänsehaut
noch immer von die
spinne die in diesem fall stufe spion
auf dem schiff okay eines tages erhielt
der kapitän eines großen handelsschiffs
einer anonymen nachricht in der es hieß
dass sich an bord einen piraten spion
auffällt
die übeltäter haben vor das schiff zu
kapern und warten in der nähe auf ein
signal ihres agenten ok kapitän war
ernsthaft beunruhigt und nach einer sehr
kurzen untersuchung machte er drei
verdächtige aus der erste war schon ein
alter seemann der über 50 war
ich bin definitiv kein spion denn ich
arbeite in dieser firma schon seit über
20 jahren sagte er
der zweite verdächtige war ein 30
jähriger namens peter der ebenfalls
seine verbindung mit den piraten
geleugnet hat ob er kann weder pirat
noch spion sein
wie stellen sie es sich vorher kapitän
ich kann doch nicht einmal schwimmen
sagte petra als letzten hat der kapitän
einen neuling namens sam zu sich
bestellt der erst 18 war
ich habe erst vor zwei monaten einen job
auf dem schiff angetreten aber ich bin
kein spion ehrenwort ich schwör's rief
er seinen vorgesetzten aufgeregt
entgegen
der kapitän hat alle drei aufmerksam
angehört und nachher den schuldigen
enttarnt ok erraten auf wen er getippt
hat und warum
also im ersten moment würde ich denken
der 18-jährige weil er halt so ich
schwör's ehrenwort ich bin es nicht
aber die werden wahrscheinlich einen
anderen grund haben ich sage einfach mal
der in der mitte weil er sagt er kann
nicht schwimmen will ich keine ahnung
falls ihr dachte dass peter der spion
war dann hattet ihr völlig recht hat
behauptet dass er nicht schwimmen können
aber warum hier ein seemann ist ja auf
einem schiff arbeitet ein echter seemann
muss schwimmen können dh
das war jetzt wirklich der grund genau
so bin ich auch durch mein abi gekommen
tulpen und äpfel
ein mann hat den besitzer eines
benachbarten landhauses verklagen ja und
mut auslöser war der zweig eines
apfelbaums im nachbargarten ob er über
den zaun in sein grundstück hineinragt
und zwar direkt über sein bett mit
seltenen schulden
der kläger behauptete dass die
herabfallenden äpfel seine blumen kaputt
machen würden und verlangte dass der
nachbar den zweig sofort absägte und ihm
eine entschädigungssumme auszahlte aber
das gericht hat nach der anhörung des
klägers beschlossen dass er der wahre
schuldige in diesem fall ist warum
selbstverständlich war der richter ein
ehrenhafter mann den der besitzer des
apfelbaums unmöglich hätte bestechen
können war der gut darüber nach also mal
ganz kurz zusammengefasst das sind zwei
leute der eine hat hier seinen grund
schon der andere hier der hier hat ein
paar tulpen und der härten apfelbauern
der apfelbaum ragt ein bisschen rüber
und er hier wird ihnen jetzt verklagen
weil der apfelbaum überragt und
eventuell seine toten kaputt machen
könnte
ich steh krasse auf dem schlauch alzen
feuerwehrmanns praktikant wenn ihr
wenigstens einmal gesehen habe wie
tulpen und apfelbäume wachsen bis dir
bestimmt das erstere zu dem zeitpunkt wo
äpfel anfang reif zu werden längst
aufgeblüht sind hell weil sie erst
herunter fallen wenn sie ausgereift sind
okay heimtückische tulpen besitzer muss
also vorsätzlich am2 gerüttelt haben um
von seinen nachbarn eine entschädigung
ausgezahlt zu bekommen
lösegeld ein erfolgreicher geschäftsmann
namens mister thompson hatte zwei söhne
der ältere hieß james und der jüngere
belegen
eines tages rief mister thomson bei der
polizei an und teilte mit bebender
stimme mit das baby entführt wurde
als die polizisten bei ihm zu hause
ankam erzählte der geschäftsmann dass
die täter gleich nach der führung bei
ihm anriefen und verlangten eine halbe
millionen dollar gleich am heutigen tag
zu bezahlen
das geld muss in einen park gebracht
werden der unweit des hauses von mister
thomson liegt der erschrockene vater
trieb die erforderliche summe
unverzüglich auf und sein älterer sohn
schlug ihm vor den koffer mit dem geld
den entführern zu übergeben
der bursche auf halbem weg in den park
war hat ihn jemand von hinten auf den
kopf gehauen entriss ihm den koffer und
lief davon
die ermittler fragten james ob er es
geschafft hat sich das gesicht des
täters genau anzusehen er meinte es wäre
unmöglich gewesen da der angreifer ihn
von hinten attackiert hat alles was ich
sah waren seine blaue hose und ein t
shirt mit einem ferkel bild auf der
brust war erklärte james traurig diese
angaben haben den polizisten ausgereicht
um den täter festzunehmen wer hat den
kleinen billy entführt
was sind das für räte also erst hab ich
überlegt das ist der große bruder selbst
war weil er irgendwie geld von seinem
vater halt haben wollte der anscheinend
ziemlich reich ist aber dann hab ich mir
auch so gedacht so wendorff dann selbst
das geld der hinbringt klar da macht es
wieder sind aber wenn er dann selbst die
box wurde niemand das geld geklaut ganz
komisch ganz komisch normalerweise
bringt hat auch nicht eine zivilperson
einfach das geld drüber
nachdem schon die medien eingeschaltet
sind das war dann die polizei und alles
also ganz komisch kann ich auch nicht
beantworten ihr habt sicherlich erraten
wer in dieser geschichte der bösewicht
ja es ist james person von mister
thomson
der bursche hätte vielleicht ein
kriminal genie werden können aber er hat
sich bei seinen aussagen in widersprüche
verstrickt wie soll er ein bild auf der
brust des täters gesehen haben wenn er
ihn von hinten geschlagen hat und danach
geflohen ist
stimmt
vor allem hatte der typ halt auch vorne
im pflaster wenn du doch von hinten
geschlagen
ok wenn er nach vorne fällt aber das
sind so sachen das ist so da das sind
keine krassen rätsel sondern ziemlich
einfache rätsel die man aber trotzdem
nicht lösen kann und genau das steht
auch im titel luca entführte mädchen in
einer stadt hat lange zeit eine
kidnapper bande ihr unwesen getrieben
okay nur auf mädchen mit gefärbten
haaren abgesehen hatte der polizei ist
es gelungen ihr geheimversteck ausfindig
zu machen und in erfahrung zu bringen
dass der kopf der bande eine
dunkelhaarige frau war als die
polizisten bei den tätern herein
geplatzt waren konnten sie alle
festnehmen und mit ausnahme der banden
anführerin
dafür konnten sie drei mädchen befreien
hier sieht sie jetzt im bild die erste
sagte dass die bereits seit drei monaten
als geisel gehalten wird die zweite
wurde vor fünf monaten entführt und die
dritte wird seit fast einem jahr
gefangen gehalten und haye ist die
banden anführerin vielleicht eine von
ihnen
nicht wird mal ganz grob sagen sie
weil man ihren schwarzen ansatz sieht
dass sie jetzt wegen schwarzen haaren
aber dann denke ich mir wenn ich nicht
auffallen will wird die sich
wahrscheinlich die haare färben wenn die
wissen das ist eine schwarze ist und das
zehn mal betont haben aber hier sieht
man heute den schwarzen ansatz und sie
hier keinen schwarzen ansatz also safe
die in der mitte ist relativ easy oder
die täterin gab sich tatsächlich für
einen führungs opfer aus und das war das
mädchen nummer eins denn wenn sie vor
drei monaten entführt worden wäre wären
ihre haare stark nach gewachsen und das
könnte man sehen
aber so wie sie jetzt aussieht muss sie
ihre haare erst vor kurzem gefärbt haben
nehmen sie fest dass checke ich ja vorn
und hinten nicht
habt ihr die begründung verstanden
hey ich bin sogar zu blöd die lösung zu
verstehen wenn euch das video allerdings
dennoch gefallen hat dann schreibt mir
einen daumen hoch
in die bewertungen schreibt mir zudem
gerne in die kommentare was ihr alles
lösung content also hattet ihr auch so
viele richtig wie ich oder war die
komplett daneben anliegen hatte
allerdings befinden uns jetzt auch schon
im auto meiner lieben freunde findet ihr
am 1 mai die eigene wenn wir dort gut
könnte man kann kostenlos abonnieren
dadurch verpasste keine videos mehr wenn
ihr schon jetzt hat der klickt kann auf
die glocke dann bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen und hier ist ein video
verlinkt das auf meinem zeit kanal
online gegangen ist
also schaut sich gerne an jetzt glaube
ich nicht heute online gegangen sondern
die tage verlinkt ich war nicht da
irgendwas de